are you trying to get healthy for 2022
well january is also known as the
january it's time to help inspire people
to try vegan cuisine bianca holman has
the report
i was coming home from the sanctuary and
was looking out the window and saw a
truck full of pigs being taken to
slaughter and that was just it i
it was just that moment i was like right
i'm never eating meat again diana
edelman is one of more than 9 million
vegans in the u.s
she chose to go meatless for animal
rights but for many others it's health
related it's becoming more accessible
now now than ever so it's really cool to
see and to kind of
see more people go vegan now that there
are easier ways to do so whether it's
weight loss for the environment or to
improve heart and kidney health vegan
cuisine is growing in popularity from
fast food joints like kfc's new vegan
nuggets to vegan girl scout cookies and
now plant-based dishes can be found at
fine dining restaurants a lot of the
team members that joined us to open
berries
uh are vegan actually and we wanted
something to to cater to them to their
families when they came in because
that's important to us
so it started off selfishly and then it
became something that that was pretty
important yeah seeing lua be from
barry's downtown prime at circa says
they've had a great response from the
vegan community he says restaurant staff
is trained on how to properly serve
health conscious clients no longer are
they a second thought in the world of
hospitality it's not just a trend it's
it's a way for us to show respect and
pay homage to that lifestyle or to that
moral a choice to become a vegan or
whatever the case may be for anyone who
wants to become vegan to see these
big name restaurants embracing this
really shows you what the future is and
also i think sends a message to other
restaurants that you know you're going
to have to catch up now during las vegas
vegan dining month a portion of proceeds
from participating vegan restaurants
will be donated to the churchill
foundation bianca holman live local now